let's roll here okay finally throw out
all your opening books actually there's
still some it good information in those
opening books that you have when it
comes to Fisher random control the
center get developed but what do you do
when a knight is in the corner mmm
well one thought was this and then
Knight here but I am neglecting my
Center I'm neglecting the center if I do
that what about this instead or this
these are my two candidate moves I have
to prevent this two pawns in the center
in some way I think this is a good way
to do it I can always just play the
copycat game I think you'd do that in
most situations maybe it is actually
best to do this I'm gonna do this it'd
be a different story I think if I had a
knight on let's say b8 or d8 as a
follow-up to go behind the pond and have
additional control over d4 so now that I
have a pond fixed and on a dark square
in the center this guy becomes bad and
he becomes good he's bad and he's good
because of the light pond being fixed so
what does this really mean it means
maybe I should consider bringing my
bishop out before I play a pawn to f6 or
something I don't know
Bishop here might be or Bishop here is
that an idea maybe
oh man let's see Bishop here Knight here
okay let's scratch that idea I don't
like that Knight here
okay let's do that copycat copycat
variation symmetrical King pawn opening
what do you call this symmetrical King
pawn king prawn Oh what else
ah let's see four okay now this quail
actually I didn't even do a quick I
didn't look quickly about what it is my
opponent can maybe be attacking or
what's unprotected nothing was
unprotected from the initial position
the king guards these three the bishop
guards four and the queen guards these
three what should I be doing here let me
see I really want to do something my
dark square bishop maybe this move is
decent or wait a second might there be
something with pawn push bishop here no
if I do this then the bishop plays here
real soon hmm pawn push might be on the
cards I'm gonna do this I was ready to
once again copy white but I think they
strike first in the center I don't know
if I like that idea I have to be very
cautious of this f5 Square and d5 square
then I could play here this Knight could
eventually play here or here and maybe
there's some lines where the knight can
be playing to the edge and if I kick him
away he can maybe play to f6 but my
bishop is watching out for that what do
you do or next I'm really tempted to get
my bishop out to one of these two
squares maybe this is a good one
actually yeah I should have considered
this this is something I can do that
white cannot mimic I don't have my pawn
on f6 so I could play here but this
bishop can't play here however if I do
this now it's not this Knight move that
can be a bother it's this move if I do
this in the knight moves I'm okay with
this exchange again this is my bad
Bishop and this is why it's good bishop
by the way if you're curious about when
I started learning about I don't think
I've ever shared this before but um I
couldn't recall the first time I started
learning about good and bad bishops and
it came I think when I was either
approaching a 1,900 level or already in
nineteen hundred level that's when I
really started to pay much more
attention to that having a positional
sense so anyhow Bishop g5 I think I'm
liking Bishop g5 actually I'm not liking
Bishop g5
I'm liking Knight here just so I could
play this pawn up and stop these Knights
if they get excited about going to the
f5 square if this pot ever moves to kick
my knight away I could play here maybe
it's not a support point but hopefully
this Knight becomes a bit difficult to
deal with
maybe the knight I'll play it back if
Knight here pawn push pawn push is no
good because after I capture the knight
this Queen would be placing this Jeep on
and a pin and I could take here and then
play here and I'm heading this pawn oh
this is good this is good for me because
it can't be conveniently defended if you
push here then the knight has what
square available d3 what now I didn't
touch on the different ways you can
castle if I'm to Castle queenside I need
to move this rook in this Bishop if I'm
to Castle kingside
I need to move both bishops and Queen up
to Castle kingside
I'm just netting this pawn for free
what's the trick is there any trick or
was white just realizing that there
wasn't a good way to defend this I'm not
seeing what the
the trick is here I'm gonna grab this
guy and move forward if the Queen plays
here to hit my knight I could play til
it's a f5 hit their Knight and defend my
knight I need to get my queen out she's
she could definitely do a lot more not a
lot of mobility right here for as long
as the queen is on g8 and I think what
one of the recent I better hang on I do
this ooh I gotta watch out for maybe
Bishop here my rook is maybe trapped
what I was going to say is recently I've
been doing some if you're on Twitter for
the Facebook page
I've been putting out some trivias just
like little simple things and then like
five hours later just posting the answer
and one of the more recent ones was
which chess piece has the same amount of
mobility on a corner square as it does
on a center square if you didn't already
know is it's it's been posted by now on
that so anybody know what that one is
quickly twitch chat same amount which
piece is the same amount of mobility on
a center square as it does in a corner
square so following up Bishop to c6 this
Bishop wants to I this pawn and I'm
close to being able to just Castle
kingside and in fact that's really the
direction I think is best so and yes if
you are guessing at
if you're guessing rook you are correct
and number-wise 14 let's play here I
want to support this I don't want this
bishop to get at my King and actually
look at that out that hope that whole
diagonal is filled with pieces or pawns
just then that's kind of rare to see
that whole diagonal like that I want to
take with my queen cuz now I'm in a spot
to Castle kingside
and maybe even deliver a check so this
is blown wide open about 30 minutes yeah
30 seconds each and here's castling drop
the King on top of the rook if you're
unfamiliar with chess960 ins let's go
with let's give a check and go with this
rook now they can't castle this rook is
uh in a tough spot here I Rock so let's
get doubled I want to throw a rook to e1
let's go with this Queen Trey this is a
mate Queen takes bishop is a mate threat
I'm on the Queen actually no time
everything's falling no good solution
here less than ten each pretty move mode
pre moves okay good game that was an
interesting setup to work with love it I
love the Fisher randoms let's see how
else is there to start out here I guess
you could be here for days on end my
opponent is saying f3 really didn't work
did it um yeah I guess some I mean it
has its points doesn't it I mean you're
ready to maybe play so that's this right
here
I mean f3 has its points of maybe trying
to get in this advanced you know maybe
maybe you could just say you know I'm
gonna make it work because okay I
stopped your let's say push in the
center
if there's a downside it's you know
hemming in the light square bishop you
could forget about it coming to g4 h5
but on the other hand it supports your
Center it allows your queen to see it's
facilitating d4 and if I'm to stop it
and I do maybe you could say you know
what no I really want to get it in and
you could do that with maybe c3 and say
you know what I'm gonna play my
LightSquared Bishop to b3 and place your
knight in a pin or beep and be in a
position to let's say take my night out
and then BAM d4 you've established two
pawns in the center and I have to always
wonder what I have to wonder are you
gonna push forward are you gonna capture
you're gonna get a gain space am I
getting pushed around there's a lot of
things that I have to start to question
as soon as you have two pawns
established on both the d4 and e4 so I
think you could be making this work I'm
not so sure that this is bad but maybe
following up with C 3 and d 4 as a way
to go and what other possibility is
there to run with I guess there's a well
there's a there's a ton isn't there I
don't even want to go at that let's just
go with the move that was played hard
when to argue with establish a pond in
the center and I felt they need to do
the same so I think that that's a my
quick suggestion out of this arrangement
look into c3 and getting in d4 build
that Center you have it supported this
guy's uh he's in a good spot get in at
d4 move baby okay let me close out good
game as usual honey I love the 960s